I'm not sure if you heard about this but
the 2016 election was completely bananas
Trump and Hillary were actually only
part of it as there were other
characters from Bernie and Jeb to Marco
and Ted the election also caused the
implosion of the mainstream media and
set us on a path that has hashtag Magga
racing towards hashtag resistance with
the rest of us caught right in the
middle
Ohio Governor John Kasich was one of the
more moderate voices in a campaign
season that was short on moderation as a
fiscally conservative socially liberal
Republican I see Kasich as someone who
has some of the right ideas but whose
timing just wasn't right for the madness
of 2016
Kasich steam reached out to us a couple
days ago and we have him in studio today
totally unscripted and unedited with no
advanced knowledge of the topics or
questions I think this is exactly the
way we need to be hearing from our
politicians and I hope that this
interview helps deal us in on these
conversations in the near future
[Music]
joining me today is the author of the
new book two paths America divided or
United a former Republican presidential
candidate and the current governor of
the great state of Ohio Governor John
Kasich welcome to the Rubin report
that's a really good television voice
house thank well we were just sitting
here you were kind of normal and that
you were like dude you know it was like
Ted Baxter very good ah Ted Baxter I
like the reference that did not go over
me well you know I like of course
everybody else watching their little he
is but that's okay they could google it
some of my millennial people won't get
it but they should google who Ted Baxter
is that would that would be good for
them so first what I wanted to start
with you I'm incredibly excited you're
here and it's interesting because your
people reached out to us about four days
ago they said the governor would like to
come in and then we quickly set this up
nobody said oh we have to talk about
this or we can't talk about this you sat
down here about two minutes ago and you
said whatever you want to do is fine and
I feel like that is partly what's lost
in politics right now that we're gonna
just do this well it's not just lost in
politics I see it lost in a lot of
things you know I mean I met with this
big car company and like they had these
guys come in to see me and it was like
they were totally scripted and you know
so I think you know life is having fun
life is you know being able to to be
real and the reason why we wanted to do
this is I actually kind of saw part of
one of your shows and this media is
really amazing a lot of people don't get
it and I'm starting to get it and I have
some people around me who say this is
really a way to keep your voice out
there you know that's what I want to be
able to have a constructive positive
voice to help our country and this is
another avenue that i'm glad no one else
has found it yeah in my profession yeah
so we can be a first mover which I I
really I really like and I like the fact
that we can actually have a conversation
longer than just a couple sound bites
yeah do you ever worry that because
we've lost the ability to do this that
the sound bite world is what's causing
so many of the
well that was what happened in a
campaign it was all you know we didn't
do it but these other campaigns and I
had advice from some people who had run
before make sure you get your little
thing out there so you can blow up the
television Morning News and you know and
it's like tricks you know mm-hmm that's
not a good thing and look people I saw I
saw thing on the side yesterday it said
email me please we have to talk yeah I
think the look I I didn't have a
smartphone for a long time I have I've
had an iPad and I got it in the very
beginning but I didn't have a smartphone
and people would laugh at me but I
didn't need this stuff during the day
you know I didn't need to have
basketball scores or look at the weather
25 times or you know some kind of
headline in the news or my emails
because I have people that can you know
tell me if there's a crisis they tell me
I go okay well let's see what it is but
I got my smart phone and now the best
thing about it is that I can text but I
find that when I text you know what it
does is it creates a laziness right you
don't have to go through a conversation
yeah now don't you think
look you have a cup you have a show here
where people talk this is what you think
about it don't you think this is a
problem I mean I think that resetting
our ability to talk and actually think
and and sit across from somebody and
make some eye contact and really try to
understand what they think I think that
is almost the most important thing that
we've given up in these last couple
years it was the trade-off between all
these devices and the immediate response
so what do we do about it
this I mean I honestly think that you
come in here right now and you're people
being brave enough to say yeah it's not
like I have my people you know these are
people that work around yeah kind of
support me and help me they're friends
and but this whole you know sort of
funny we were you go on these shows on
regular television which I think are
really important and you get you know
two million people to see you but if you
are like hanging out with Logan Paul
that's 16 million subscribers it's like
and you know the funny thing about it
is that people can't see it really now
but that's not really true because I
think probably you're in demand now and
you can go out and make talks and people
show up to see you yeah but it's kind of
an invisible world to those who were
kind of hooked on television right you
understand what I mean by that I do so
how do we how do we bridge that I don't
know but you know what's I think it's
called what's news it was really
fantastic and there were a couple of
million views and and I liked it you
just have to keep doing it it's part of
why I wanted to be here
I mean I look you I pull up here you've
got a studio in your garage yeah it's
it's cool it's neat and you know you
don't have to go very far right yes like
commutes about 10:00 you know that way
the hard thing has got to be getting
compelling guests there's got to be a
hard thing to do how do you go about
doing that
well fortunately a lot of people are
coming to this medium now and a lot of
the guests that you asked me right
before we started all these books here I
mean most of the I think well virtually
every single one except the Carl Sagan
but are there any of them that are
interesting there's a lot like they're
very boring and I know there's some
great books there by by many of my
guests from Steven Pinker and Sam Harris
and Scott Adams and yeah plenty of I see
you have one here on John Adams so I
have it we did a president's week a
couple weeks ago John Adams so you're
getting you're getting good over the
cone we're getting was it was it you
know what a lot of times when I am with
the press I'm actually curious about
them and they don't like it when I'm
asking them stuff okay it must have been
hard in the beginning right Owain it's
hard to build anything I mean you know
you know that but I one of the things
that I consistently tell my audience is
it's cool that a lot of the beliefs that
I have you know I fall a little more
within classical liberalism and
libertarianism a lot of the beliefs
about doing things for yourself and I've
built this business with the same ideas
that I try to talk about here
some of which I think we're gonna get to
and it's kind of a beautiful thing not
if I keep not if you keep going yeah all
right let me ask you a couple of
questions as long as you're here so I
thought just first I thought we just a
little bit about growing up what kind of
family you grew up in I feel like people
never do that in politics anymore we go
to immediately what everybody kind of
mocks me because I say my father was a
mailman and so the people write that and
they're like
cynical and all that but
I grew up in a town that was over I mean
I don't think I ever met a Republican
not in my town my Uncle Harry was a
Republican they say we didn't listen
much to him he's a great guy but you
know it was blue-collar and you know is
sort of these some of these people you
would define as kind of the Trump people
you know who felt they've been left
behind so you know as a result of that I
guess I that's why I'm a populist but a
positive populist not a negative
populist positive that we can do it we
can together we can we can rise and
that's a great place to come from
because you really have a sense you have
a sense of people you know and it's not
just the upper crust we respected the
upper crust I can remember saying to my
father one time daddy what about the
rich he said well we don't hate the rich
we want to be the rich you know and so
it was great god-fearing conservative
Democrat good values faith was a was a
part of my early childhood which I
normally drifted away from when I went
to college you know it's like Augustine
he says you know I needed I know I need
to be committed to God but just not
right now I have a couple parties to go
so you know we all drift away and I've
drifted I'm not drifted I've come
roaring back into that but common sense
right
freewheeling sometimes it puts people
off a little bit the way I am because
I'm pretty direct and but the other
thing is I was telling somebody the
other day that you know I don't want
people to be confused about my positions
on anything and so if somebody says well
I think it's blue and I might say well
no I think it's red and they most people
would expect me to say okay well
consider that and I'm like no no I just
don't think that and I think to some
degree people don't get it so it takes a
little bit of time for people to come to
understand me yeah
all right well that's what we're gonna
do here for the next hour oh you
mentioned a couple interesting things
there so you didn't grow up in a
Republican family personnel and you just
use the phrase conservative Democrat
yeah so one of the things I talk a lot
about here is that it seems to me before
we get into your party that the
conservative Democrat or the Blue Dog
Democrat or sort of the moderate down
there a lot of them were buddies of mine
in Congress you know great friends do
they really exist anymore I think this
is I think this young man in
Pennsylvania is Blue Dog Democrat from
what I can see now he got elected at 33
I think I was 30 so he's kind of
old-timer yeah but no I think that I
think in both parties it's really hard
if you're Republican you got to fear the
right and if you're a Democrat you fear
the left and it just pulls everybody
apart you know that though but but
you've managed to kind of work through
something that's sort of centrist right
somehow well I don't know what that
means you know one guy once told me the
only thing that goes down the middle of
a road are yellow lines and dead skunks
okay and I'm I'm not a but I'm a common
sense person well I guess so look I look
at an issue and say okay what do we do
about it and we look at a problem how do
we fix the problem but I'm not really
going to have an ideological force
that's pulling me back but the same time
being a conservative I want to see what
the solutions are without having to
bring bureaucracy or government and and
I'll tell you why that is it's because
government inherently is so subject to
political considerations that people
have a hard time make calling a spade a
spade it's like no no I got all these
pressures and I don't like that and so
when you go to government you can get
trapped but you get trapped with big
business to big business you know you
try to like I need this prescription you
know and somebody out here is telling me
oh no no it costs too much you know big
things like that all have always
bothered me
you know big institutions whether it's
government I grew up my dad was in a
Union I always liked unions but you know
the problem with the unions is when the
union boss is not representing a worker
and so big institutions don't throw me
where am I kind of unpredictable see
because you kind of labeled yourself a
little bit ago you said well I'm this
and that if you ask me what I am I'll
say I'm a conservative but then you will
say well but why do you think this or
that and
because I don't think we need to be
stuck right being stuck in life is
really depressing all right so tell me
about what does being a conservative
basically mean to you then if government
is a last resort yeah not as a first
resort but but I also don't think it's
like no government you know how do you
decide where that's that new user do use
judgment and you listen you have good
people around you think about things and
we're trying to price something right
now in our state somebody wants access
to stuff in our state okay it would it's
a good thing it's a good thing what they
want but I don't know what the price of
the value of it is okay so I can't just
look at what governments have done to
determine the value because I don't have
a you know I don't have a whole lot of I
don't invest a lot in that I want to go
out and talk to a variety of people and
business to say what do you think this
is worth okay and so how do I do that
people that come in and they talk and
they argue for certain things but at the
end I have to decide so I just used as
good a judgement as I can yeah do you
have a certain leeway when it comes to
sort of thinking for yourself as a
governor that maybe the Senators and the
congressmen can't have because they have
to all cannot that you don't have to
come together and work with people know
if they have to do it from with people
outside their state with massively
competing interests and things like that
I was offering budgets against
Republican presidents I mean just do
your job I mean why would you want to be
why would you want to have a television
show where you don't make it real why
would I want to be in politics no matter
where I am and not make it real I mean
what would I be there for it's really
stupid right they mean it there's if
you're not there's a lot of people there
for that well I don't want to be I don't
want to be casting aspersions or judging
them only for me why would you do that I
mean so we had a decision on Medicaid
expansion right in Ohio you know that
you know Medicaid expansion of course
right so I was really Jen Brewer in
Arizona did it which really was
kind of shocking to me but I was really
the first big state big Republican
governor who expand it was it hard no it
was a piece of cake if I'm gonna get
money that's not gonna put me in a
straitjacket from the federal government
if I can use that money to heal to help
heal or helps help to help the mentally
ill so they're not sleeping under a
bridge or living in a jail or if I can
help people who have drug addiction to
get treatment and get off of it if I can
have a lower uninsurance rate why
wouldn't I do that and because people
are gonna yell at me and fight with so
what who cares I mean I care I don't
want them to not I don't want him to be
angst in fact in my State of the State
address I was I made a talk that really
had almost nothing to do with policy it
all had all to do with basically
philosophy and the meaning of life
they say was the only State of the State
speech delivered by Governor in the
history of the world where the name camu
was discussed you know but I and I
didn't mention that because I don't want
to jab anybody in the eye but the
decision to do that to help people it's
just it's such an easy decision do you
find you have a little bit of an extra
freedom right now because you can't run
for re-election i yeah i oh now there's
a lot of talk of 2020 which I want to
end the after viewer look I mean
probably so but I've always been very
independent you know I was a military
reformer I was offering my own budgets
against President Bush I would talk on
corporate welfare reform couldn't find a
Democrat with a searchlight and the
Republicans or any other way no I've
always pretty well felt that you know I
you got to do what you have to do and am
I more free now I may be a little bit
but but I think would change I mean I
don't know what is that I would reverse
I wouldn't say well we're not going to
do this Medicaid thing yeah now if you
got us into a point where we were you
know fiscally at risk I would have to
stop it I've told everybody that but now
I don't really think so but I am having
probably more fun now
you know having a lot of fun yeah I mean
I can tell but I've been having fun you
know I ran for re-election and I and I
never even used the word Obama running
for re-election never talked about it I
just talked about a record and it was
fun and it was positive look here's the
thing
and we all need to know this we all need
to be healers in one way or another we
need to heal our family and our friends
and strangers I'm not that great a guy
okay but I know that that makes sense
and I know that it's right so it's just
a cool thing to think about and that's
why politics is so boring to me because
it's all these all these calculations
and all this crap why don't we just do a
job let's think about how to pull to
pull the country together let's make
sure that we can help people to be
lifted let's not tear somebody down
Elizabeth Warren wants to tear down all
these rich people I don't know why or
Bernie or whatever I work with Bernie it
it's you don't need to tear people down
we need to just build people up and and
put them together yeah did you ever get
into any of those philosophical
discussions with Bernie because the
class war nothing I see I see as
extremely dangerous no I know I know I
wouldn't have a conversation with Bernie
Ben Bernie and I were in the house
together he was you know really kind of
in another orbit they all thought he was
and yet you know the country's kind of
moved towards him and I think a lot of
young people are you know the one thing
that is concerning to me and I have
great faith in the Millennials and Gen
Xers but I'm not sure they understand
the consequences of losing a
representative democracy there seems to
be with some of them some appeal towards
an authoritarian figure of you am i
right on that I think you have me yeah I
haven't studied it but I've got that
sense that's not good or that you know
maybe socialism will work look and a
free enterprise system ichael novak the
great philosopher theologian said that a
free market system that is not under
laid with a set of values is bankrupt so
you have to have values you can't just
be in it to make money there has to be
something else there
where do you think those values come
from oh I think they I think that they
the easy thing to say politically easy
thing to say is they come from mom and
dad and I say to people well where do
you think mom and dad got it from right
well they got it from their parents
where do I think these virtues come from
look if you're a humanist I respect you
okay you wake up every day trying to
figure out how to make the world a
little better place I like that okay but
for me the winds of change the fads can
knock me off my path so I need something
deeper than that so I look to
theologians and I believe that we are we
are a unique form of life greater than
all other life on the earth and I think
that life is given to us by our Creator
then I think our Creator has a character
that we can learn about and that's not
only held by a Christian but also a Jew
and also Muslim we have the same kind of
view of creation and our purpose and
within those values are things like
mercy and justice and compassion and
forgiveness and you know if you play
golf that we should we have to have
Mulligan's in life because we you know I
and the danger of talking about these
things is that people want to say oh
well you don't have great values I
caught you what yeah of course I'm just
a slob on a bus trying to make it
through life you know but I kind of know
what I need to do so I think that these
values and they flow from from our
Creator and I think too much in religion
today which is turned off a lot of young
people I'm actually mentoring a young
man in faith but it's not about all this
judgment we hear it's about hope it's
about human connectedness and that's
appealing to people and it's what I
think is true about faith and virtue
it's not confining it's it's enlarging
it doesn't make you smaller it makes you
bigger and today in religion we see a
lot of forces that are counter
to that and I don't like it yeah well
it's interesting to me because my
audience knows that Thomas Jefferson was
my fav favorite founder and I go to the
Jefferson Memorial often in DC and I try
to read those big plaques and to me
they're as relevant now as they were you
know 200 some odd years ago where he
talked abut you know they talk about a
creator at the same time they're talking
about why church and state have to be
separate sure they know and I think
that's really to the heart of what
you're saying well I think first of all
we don't want the government being
involved in religion we don't want that
we want though in a free society look
freedom means we have to learn to
self-govern and if every time we turn
around this is a big thing about
Facebook now they didn't self govern
right I mean we can pass all these rules
but you know guys like you and me were
met we're born to figure out how to get
around the rules okay right
I mean want to be free that's why we're
both here like what I'm saying is that
you can't you if you're going to have
freedom people have to have
self-restraint and the less
self-restraint we have the more the
government tries to impose things and
the more they impose things the less
freedom we have so I don't want it I
believe that that our our faith system
and again if you're a humanist that's
cool with me that's fine with me because
you're trying to do good every day I
just it can't work for me because I get
to knocked off kilter by the culture
today and the winds of change but with
that system it it it reinforces the
sense of freedom
so it's interesting you've referenced
culture a couple times and one of the
things that seem pretty obvious from an
outside perspective the 2016 election
was that Trump captured the culture good
or bad he captured that he captured the
internet culture the reason that your
that can by law and I was like 80,000
votes so we have to keep it in
perspective and the trouble is but he's
a negative populist I'm a positive
populist the people that I grew up with
when they're out of work or whatever my
message is this is terrible but let's go
fix it I think the negative populist
message is well you're out of work
because that guy over there took it away
from you I mean he took your stuff away
and that creates a bitterness and an
anger and there's also a sense that that
can translate into victimhood I'm a
victim would you ever like to be a
victim my I do not want to be a victim
don't you think it's very easy
particularly if you have other people
around that want to be a victim now I'm
not going to condemn them but it's easy
to fall into that if somebody tells you
you don't have something because
somebody else took it so what we need to
do is if you were to go to say
Youngstown Ohio they talk about that a
lot of international news and I was a
steelworker or I worked in a coal mine
in West Virginia or whatever we have in
Ohio working with with one of the tech
companies we have a list of all the job
openings okay now if you're a victim and
I come to you and I say you are coal
miner or you're steel worker and this
would be hard for me so listen I can
show you this internet stuff right and I
can get you one of these jobs you don't
have to become an expert but I can show
you stuff if I'm a victim I may not want
to do it but if I if I give that person
a message Hey look at these jobs it pays
good money your family will be helped
help will be healthier your children
will be healthier you will have more
self-respect but you know it's tough
where you are I understand is the better
message then well you're just a victim
and we're gonna go and punish people
right that's I don't know it doesn't
work for the good for the mental health
of our society yeah so I mean that's a
great phrase right there cuz we seem to
be in a mental I just came up with it
that's pretty good you're right don't go
back and hey roll the tape they should
roll the tape yeah we're long past there
I'm sorry tape there's no tape anymore
so but- pop and get the electrons back
sorry no no so negative populism did you
see that train coming because it's yummy
that that Trump grabbed it as a
manifestation he's not he didn't create
this people for a long time have felt at
rich get richer and the poor get poor
people in my party have ignored that may
be to some degree early on I did too I
thought well what's that all about
but it's true that you see these chasms
and those are dangerous hmm because you
know we need to believe that all this
wealth and everything changes they say
that the ocean always kind of flips
upside down and that's what we need to
see in our country that you know people
on the bottom can get to the top and we
look at Bezos guy selling books out of
his garage yeah look at you it's just a
matter of time till you're a billionaire
you know yeah you you know he's
delivering me a lot of stuff every day
but you see what I'm saying I mean it is
possible to rise in a free society with
a free enterprise and do you think we
stopped selling that correctly because I
don't think we talked about it yeah that
young people now they starting to think
that socialism is cool yeah I don't I
don't get that i mean well cuz it sounds
good you know like let's share I can
tell you a really interesting story yeah
my chief of staff there's that you know
that show that you get on your phone at
nine o'clock Eastern it's like they ask
questions and you answer them my kids
have done it for a while they don't do
it anymore I don't know what what the
show is called well anyway she and her
kids two daughters they listen to this
every every night at nine o'clock and
they work together and so she said one
day to her kids why don't I I'll be on
one phone and you got you'll be on your
phone and and joy you'll be on your
phone and let's have a competition
they looked at her like she was crazy
they're like why would we do that you
know so you know when I guess what I'm
saying about that is the idea of
community and together is good but we
don't want that to erode the basic sense
that competition is good as long as it's
played fairly yes and everybody has a
chance to compete so really what you're
talking about you're sort of talking
about individualism and how we can
create groups around that as opposed to
collectivism right yeah really the
thrust of this write that down that's a
good one individual and collective ISM
but if you're a young person you go I
don't know what's wrong with that
but but look there my hope because they
would rather take a job that pays less
if the job has meaning look at what
they're doing in parkland look at what
these young people are doing across this
country and using social media to have a
voice I mean it's it's really awesome I
mean it's it gets me really pumped up ya
see I think we need a new era of
activism and citizenship and by the way
we're wheats fixate all the time on the
leader okay
did you see that movie on Churchill a
darkest hour I didn't see it yet I just
saw a lot of him in the crowd why don't
you doing Gary Oldman I know I gotta get
out there it's time to man now I'll do
it tonight I'm giving you my word
now I'm oh you have my word yeah anyway
here's the thing I'm watching it tonight
in that movie and this is made-up stuff
he gets on he gets goes down and gets on
the subway and he's talking to people
and they're like you we're not giving in
and they they they embolden him set the
fire in him I'm not telling you that
that he wasn't a great leader because he
clearly he was but it was a bottom up
and a top down I mean when we think
about the civil rights movement I mean
they didn't the the great leaders Martin
Luther King Day me get help
politicians were afraid of him including
JFK they were all afraid of him
and what happened it was it was from the
street up a lot of social change the end
of the Vietnam War how much longer would
the generals have said we were winning
and by the way look at Afghanistan they
keep saying old word victories just to
cut the corner yeah terrible and so you
have a situation here where you can't
just expect change in the country
because I have elected a good I have a
new good coach so therefore I'm going to
win a basketball game it doesn't work
that way it works both ways yeah good
leader but a great group of people that
drive you know the drive change
how dangerous then is that cult of
personality that we've now made around
the president and I'm not just talking
about Trump here I mean even with Obama
and plenty of the other presidents that
we think that somehow the executive
branch is one person is going to fix it
well you know there's a book that I I
don't know that I'm like I don't have a
lot of things up here I'm getting your
life book might be okay go the book is
not here it is a book that says this and
I have never talked about this before
like on television I was with a great
preacher got 6,000 people he's in the
Silicon Valley he's very grace oriented
and hopeful and he's just he's a PhD and
psychology he's just got all this stuff
all this talent and I was asking him I
said I keep telling people it's bottom
up not top down
he said well John it's interesting
because a man wrote a book and the book
says that when pieces of our society
start to erode let's think about it
Facebook Wells Fargo
Equifax you know the scandal around
around Volkswagen sports you've got guys
that you know got had brain injuries but
the league isn't helping them and
they're living in a car the families are
destitute or Hollywood we need to say
anything there yeah you look across the
board and we're seeing an erosion of
what we really want right so there is a
tendency this man maintains that I'm
fascinated to read this book that we now
start looking to politics to solve these
problems in other words we look at
politicians or government to use in a
sense coercion to restore things to the
right balance and it just doesn't work
that way really in practicality now I'm
the governor of the state seventh
largest state I've it's a very powerful
executive position but I can't just give
heed extermo pare and expect it to work
the people have to be engaged and assent
and do things they have to self-govern
they have the lifts and so this is a
very very I think this
like the next thing to think about to me
it's the next wave you know what I love
what I think has been fun because of my
friends and because of the my mind in a
way it works I'm kind of always looking
for the next thing and I can kind of
sense the next thing you know and I
believe this is something that really
needs to be talked about I mean it's
virtue its religion it's doing well by
doing good it's driving ourselves from
the bottom up it's not trying to vest
all this power and a handful of people
in the government because I think it's
futile yeah I hate to tell you this but
in a weird way you don't sound like a
politician but I think you could take
that as a cop
no I'm look I'm a public official I'm a
CEO of a state I'm sick of politics
drives me crazy because I see that in
the middle of trying to do things we're
all weak we're all everybody's weak and
we're all susceptible to certain
pressures you know and and I'm like we
need to run through that door and
they're like oh no no no no no who's
slow down here you know and all that
kind of stuff and it's it's here's the
problem with politics you know you could
sit next to somebody your entire
lifetime in an office job and never
really know what they think but in
politics people get called out mm-hmm
it's really interesting they get called
out and it's in some ways it's not fair
because it's almost like an x-ray like
you know you and I could know each other
we could hang out we could watch
basketball games and never ever get into
my finding out how you make decisions in
a really tough situation but with
politics you're gonna have to vote and
if you vote wrong you're afraid you're
gonna lose I mean it really it really is
an amazing process and it's frustrating
you
[Music]